- Hi, I'm Hannah.
I'm the world's OK-est mom,
and I'm here to give you
some moderately helpful advice
about some stuff you wanna talk about.
So a few episodes ago,
we talked about what it's
like to lose your virginity,
and the text response was huge.
And one text that I kept
getting from all of you girls
was about the topic we're
gonna discuss tonight.
Tonight we're gonna talk
about female masturbation.
That just sounds awful.
It's like a terrible word, you know?
This is why I have to
drink for this episode.
So first, is it OK to masturbate?
Yes, it's OK!
It's totally fine, just do it.
Bye!
No, I'm just kidding.
I think a lot of the questions of is it OK
comes from people having feelings of guilt
or feelings of doubt or
being raised with beliefs
that make it seem like
it's not a good thing.
And I'm not encouraging you
to go against your beliefs.
If it's something that makes you feel bad
or something that makes you feel guilty,
you don't have to do it.
You can totally live without it.
It's not a life or death situation.
The purpose of it is
to make you feel good.
So if it doesn't, don't do it.
But that being said, I feel like there's
a double standard where
it's OK for guys to do it
and widely accepted that guys can do it,
but for women, it's a
little bit more hush-hush,
like nobody wants to know.
Like, kind of pretend like you don't.
I guarantee just as many women do it,
if not more, definitely more.
Oh my god, you ever had sex with a guy?
You gotta do it.
(laughter)
Next, how often?
Ultimately, it varies
from person to person.
There's no schedule for masturbating.
It's not like I have my
Wednesday 7:00 PMs blocked off,
like, masturbation.
No, it's just when the time is right.
You never know.
You could be like alone eating ice cream,
watching Forensic Files on a Sunday night
and just being like...
All right, why not?
Though some women do
it as much as every day
or multiple times a day.
Some women do it maybe once a month.
It just varies based on
how much time you have
and how much you need it.
So don't feel like there's
a certain amount of times
that you should be doing it
or should not be doing it.
It's whatever works for you,
whatever makes you comfortable,
and whatever you can accommodate.
I, OK, for me, I'm a very sleepy mom,
so with just about everything,
sleep is gonna take priority,
so it doesn't really
happen that often for me
because at the end of the
day, I'd rather sleep.
So next, do women watch porn?
Uh, some of 'em, yeah.
Not all of us, it just
depends from person to person.
And for me, personally, I
just don't really watch porn,
especially heterosexual porn
'cause I'm watching it like, ugh,
first of all, that wiener's too big.
You're doing this for way too long.
That can't be comfortable.
That's gotta be sore by now.
You're not having an orgasm
from just a penis jabbing you.
Like, it's just not very realistic for me.
But really, my opinion is
not the end all, be all.
Like, some women like it.
Some women don't.
Some women like other types of porn.
It's really a case-by-case basis.
So do women watch porn?
Yes.
Should you watch porn?
I don't know, if you want to.
For me, I get more out of
like, a heartfelt text than
watching porn. (laughs)
So next, do girls masturbate to dick pics?
I feel like typically, no.
If it's a girl and it's a
dick pic from her boyfriend,
I feel like maybe that'd be
more incentive to masturbate to it
because it's what's behind
the dick that matters.
But unwarranted dick pics?
You can get the fuck
out of here with those.
No body's gonna masturbate to that shit.
That gets immediately deleted.
That's one of the most offensive things
you could possibly do, is
send an unwarranted dick pick.
Ugh!
So if you're wondering if, like,
your boyfriend should send you a dick pic,
it really depends on you.
Like, do you like it?
Do you think it looks great?
Great, if so, have at it.
But if a girl hasn't
explicitly asked for it,
don't send it.
That means she don't want it.
Nobody wants to see that...
Shell-less turtle.
Next, is masturbation
better than sex for women?
Masturbation is a solo act, party of one.
But sex is a totally different experience.
That's about connecting
with another person,
and that's a very
different kind of pleasure.
For me, there's something
just totally magical
about connecting with another person,
and like, having that love and,
oh, this is so sappy, sorry.
Having that love and connection
and just like the physical
expression of your love.
There are great things
to be said about both.
And as far as wondering whether one orgasm
is better than the
other, it really depends
on the time and place and
the head space you're in.
Masturbation's great, but
it doesn't replace sex.
Just like sex doesn't
replace masturbation.
So if you like one more than the other,
that's totally fine
because it's a balance.
It's just like whatever works for you.
It's like comparing apples to oranges
or fingers to penis.
(laughter)
And last, how do I masturbate?
I'm not gonna show you how to do that.
This isn't the time or place.
I'm sorry, but, like, I'm here for you
on a, like, advice and support platform.
But beyond that, I'm not
gonna show you how to do it.
Like, try a bunch of different things.
Just see what works,
see what doesn't work.
You have the internet.
You can figure it out.
So that's all I got for today.
I'm Hannah, the world's OK-est mom.
If there's anything you
want me to talk about
in a future episode,
leave it in the comments
or you can always text me.
I don't always respond,
but I read all them
and I love to know--
(groaning)
(laughs) Sorry.
(laughter)
I'll do it again.
If there's a topic you want me
to talk about in a future episode,
leave it in the comments,
or you can text me.
This is a real number and
I do receive all the texts
and I read them all.
I don't necessarily respond to
all them because I get a lot,
but I love to see what you
guys want me to talk about.
And in the meantime,
I'm gonna go take care of some business.
And by business I mean taking a long nap.
Till next time!
(upbeat jazz)
What is that noise?